Et sans contredit, les mystères de la piété est grand.
C'est lui qui a été manifesté en chair, justifié par l'esprit,
vu des anges, prêché aux paillants, aux gentils,
cru dans les mondes, élevé dans la gloire.
Voici la plus grande révélation des dieux,
la plus incontestable révélation des dieux,
celle qui concerne la manifestation des dieux lui-même en chair,
celle qui concerne ce qui est l'Église.
Dans ces passages, comme on a déjà vu,
le but de l'apôtre Paul, c'est d'établir les bases fondamentales pour l'Église,
les vérités prioritaires par rapport à ce que l'Église est,
ce que l'Église doit faire.
Et quand on considère la description de l'Église ici,
c'est très intéressant de remarquer.
Quand on regarde l'Ancien Testament,
la préoccupation des dieux a donné tous les détails
par rapport à la construction du temple.
Et quelque part, ce que Paul est en train de dire,
c'est que par rapport à cet aspect, les choses n'ont pas changé.
Même si l'adoration dans le Nouveau Testament a été infiniment simplifiée,
la conception plus élevée de la réalité de l'Église,
elle est similaire au temple de l'Ancien Testament,
car ces temples de l'Ancien Testament étaient quelque part
une ombre qui donne l'impression d'être un prototype quelque part
du sanctuaire céleste,
sauf que les sanctuaires célestes ont toujours existé
avant que cette ombre qui était les temples
soit donnée, ou les tabernacles par exemple.
Et l'Église, elle garde quand même cet aspect, en fait,
d'être présentée dans ces passages comme la maison des dieux,
comme les temples des dieux, sauf que les temples n'ont plus faits
des pierres matérielles, ce sont les pierres vivantes.
Donc chaque individu chrétien est concerné par la description de l'Église,
et certains ont une responsabilité quelque part plus importante,
car ils sont plus rédévables devant Dieu,
car ils doivent être ceux qui occupent la position privilégiée
d'enseigner à propos des règles de la maison des dieux,
et donc ils seront rédévables devant ces dieux,
qu'il y a décrit ici comme les dieux vivants,
qui a un zèle énorme pour son Église,
qui est bien présent à l'Église, c'est-à-dire les anciens.
Donc dans les passages, Paul présente la qualification des anciens,
des diacres, qui doivent être aussi un modèle pour l'Église.
Et ce qui est important à remarquer, c'est qu'il y a une urgence.
Paul, il a voulu dire ces choses de vive voix à Timothée,
mais pour ne pas avoir les risques de tarder, il écrit.
Et il dit, pour que tu saches comment c'est conduit,
comment il faut, ce n'est pas optionnel,
comment il faut se conduire dans la maison des dieux.
Donc l'Église n'est pas livrée à l'imagination de ses pasteurs
par rapport à la manière dont ton culte doit être conduit,
par rapport aux fonctions pastorales,
par rapport aux qualifications pastorales.
On pourrait se dire, cet homme, il a une bonne connaissance biblique,
il est capable d'enseigner,
la seule faute, c'est qu'il ne gouverne pas très bien sa maison.
Mais quand même, il a majoritairement ce qu'il faut pour être pasteur.
Ça ne suffit pas.
Ce sont les qualifications.
À chaque fois, il faut, il faut, il faut,
pour la qualification des anciens, pour la qualification des diacres,
et notamment par rapport à la manière dont l'Église doit se conduire.
Donc il y a plein de choses qu'on tolère aujourd'hui dans plusieurs Églises
qu'on appelle tout simplement, ce sont les différences entre les Églises,
qui en vérité ne pourra pas l'être selon les critères de la parole de Dieu.
Mais ce qui est important à remarquer, c'est que ces hommes,
les anciens, les diacres, doivent être compris par la perspective de l'Église.
Donc Paul décrit les qualifications pour ensuite décrire l'Église.
C'est-à-dire, vous devriez avoir du zèle et du critère
pour identifier les vrais qualifiés pour les ministères,
car ils sont en train de s'occuper, d'instruire et de superviser l'Église.
Ils sont là dans une position où la prospérité de l'Église, quelque part,
sera boostée ou découragée, sera plus ou moins efficace,
selon l'accomplissement de leurs tâches.
Donc bien sûr que dans des cas exceptionnels,
les chaises vont surmonter la piété du pupitre,
et bien sûr que Dieu peut ne pas dépendre des anciens pour faire son Église avancée,
mais selon l'ordre que Christ lui-même avait établi pour l'Église,
de manière organique et de manière institutionnelle,
c'est comme ça que Dieu a dessiné l'Église.
Si on était plus critérieux vis-à-vis à la reconnaissance des vrais appelés,
on devrait contempler cet ordre,
car Paul est en train de dire « il faut ».
À nouveau, ce n'est pas optionnel.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer,
ils sont considérés vis-à-vis à l'Église.
Donc l'identité de l'Église, elle est quelque part plus importante
que les offices des anciens des diacres.
Car eux, ils doivent comprendre qu'ils sont composants et égaux
avec les autres membres de l'Église.
Ils sont aussi des pierres vivantes, les temples de Dieu.
Sauf que Dieu a ses ailes,
où il se manifeste dans l'Église et à travers l'Église.
Et ces personnes qui ont été appelées à occuper une position
des références,
des évidences,
seront les plus rédévables par rapport à la manière dont ils se portent au sein de l'Église.
Et nous sommes tous concernés à partir du moment où Paul dit
que l'importance et la sévérité des qualifications pour les leaders de l'Église,
elle est mise en évidence à cause de l'Église elle-même qui sommes nous, nous tous.
Car nous sommes ensemble
cette habitation des dieux
qui est un repère
pour les mondes
de la manifestation des dieux
entre nous, en nous
et à travers nous.
C'est ça qu'est à l'Église, l'habitation des dieux,
un repère, les mystères de la piété.
Et si
les anciens et les diacres sont, attention,
vus par la perspective
de leur liaison à l'Église,
l'Église,
elle est vue par la perspective
de la vérité
qu'elle est appelée
à proclamer.
Mais pas que.
Pas qu'elle est proclamée,
elle est appelée
à croire fermement,
préserver inébranablement,
proclamer
avec plein de convictions
et chanter
rempli d'adoration.
voici
cette église
qui est la maison des dieux,
de dieux vivants,
la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité,
la raison d'être
de l'Église,
l'identité de l'Église,
maison des dieux,
habitation de dieux
qui se manifeste entre nous,
en chair.
Et quelle est sa fonction ?
Être la colonne
et l'appui
de la vérité.
Et tout de suite,
Paul va dire,
et sans contredit,
voici les mystères
de la piété.
Donc,
les plus grands mystères
touchent à cette conception
initiale
de Noël.
Voilà pourquoi on a commencé
cette série sur Noël.
Dieu manifestait en chair.
Mais,
c'est lié
à toutes les sentences
qui sont présentées
au verset 16.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
C'est ce qui nous conduit
à la compréhension
que considérer Noël
ne doit jamais s'arrêter
au moins joueur.
C'est cette œuvre complète
qui non seulement
arrive à son plan d'accomplissement
lorsque Christ est élevé
dans la gloire,
mais en fait,
cette position définitive
à laquelle Christ a été
mis une fois qu'il a été élevé
est continuelle.
C'est la position
suprême et majeure
que l'Église devrait avoir
dans sa compréhension
pour toute la suite
de l'histoire.
Différence entre
chrétiens,
protestants,
réformés et catholiques.
Leur croix
est encore accrochée
avec un Christ
affiché comme crucifié,
ce qui est central pour nous.
Mais ils font usage de ça
de manière
à mettre l'emphase
sur la nécessité
qui se sacrifie
et se répète
à chaque fois.
Et voilà pourquoi
l'Eucharistie pour eux
c'est de sacrifier
à nouveau les Christs
à chaque fois.
Nous,
on est plutôt
avec l'auteur de Breux
lorsqu'il dit
d'une fois pour toutes.
Notre croix
quand elle est représentée,
la croix protestante
réformée,
est une croix vide
pour mettre l'emphase
sur les vrais lieux
où les médiateurs
entre Dieu et les hommes
se trouvent aujourd'hui.
Il n'est plus sur cette croix
car il est ressuscité,
car il est vivant,
il a été élevé
dans la gloire
et dès là,
il est en train
de gouverner
toutes les choses.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que cette vérité
qui a plusieurs facettes,
ici présentée
de manière résumée
et condensée
avec six facettes,
six sentences,
ce sont des vérités
qu'aucun vrai chrétien
ne peut douter.
C'est la vérité sanglier,
c'est la vérité donc absolue,
c'est la vérité inséparable
et personne ne peut douter
que Dieu a été manifesté
en chair,
qu'il est Christ
et les fils des dieux,
qu'il a été justifié
par l'Esprit,
c'est-à-dire surtout
par la ressurrection
entre les morts,
qu'il a été vu des anges,
prêché aux gentils,
cru dans les mondes
et élevé dans la gloire.
Et donc,
ce sont les faits historiques
sur lesquels sont basés
ou est basée notre foi
et c'est la vérité
que l'Église doit
pour toutes les générations
défendre,
attention,
croire fermement,
défendre
de manière inébranlable,
proclamer
avec ferme conviction
et chanter.
adorer.
Et pourquoi
on met l'emphase
sur ces chantiers ?
Car Paul est en train
de citer ici
une déclaration confessionnelle
en forme d'échange.
C'était un chant confessionnel
de l'Église primitive.
primitif.
Et donc,
la vraie adoration,
l'adoration authentique
n'arrête jamais
avec l'intellect.
Personne ne sera sauvé
sans croire
à ces vérités,
mais personne ne sera sauvé
si elle ne fait
que croire
avec l'intellect.
il faut avoir
une foi
qui est marquée
par l'expérience
de la connaissance
de cette vérité
et donc réjouir
et chanter
cette vérité.
C'est comme ça
que les anges
eux-mêmes témoignent
à propos
de la vérité
de l'Évangile.
Et donc,
ce que nous sommes
en train de voir
et de considérer,
c'est que,
pour mieux comprendre
les mieux
à propos
de notre identité
et pour prendre
des résolutions
pour cette nouvelle année
qui puissent
véritablement jouer
pour notre mieux,
nous,
en tant que chrétiens,
au lieu de nous laisser
porter
et influencer
par cet accrochage
qui caractérise
les païens,
d'avoir des résolutions
qui ne sont
qu'entrant
de s'établir
sur la prospérité
terrestre
ou les préoccupations
terrestres,
nous allons mieux faire
de mieux comprendre
quelle est notre identité,
quelle est notre nature,
quel est ce grand mystère
de la piété
qui est le plus important
de tous les mystères
qui a été révélé
particulièrement à l'Église
et qui nous touche
et qu'elle est seule
capable de porter
la plus grande pertinence,
la signification
pour notre vie,
faire quelque chose
de valeur,
c'est que Dieu
continue de se manifester
en chair
à travers nous
afin que d'autres
soient sauvés
et que d'autres
se joignent à nous
pour chanter
ces mystères
qui ont été révélés.
Et donc voilà,
l'objectif pour nous
c'est
de considérer
qu'à la mesure
où l'Église
contemple
l'effet incontestable
de cette manifestation
des dieux
en chair,
elle va intensifier
ses convictions,
elle va approfondir
ses affections
et elle va déclarer
avec plus d'ardiesse
sa confession
et son adoration
sera plus authentique,
plus attirante.
Et là,
nous passons à porter
notre contribution
dans notre génération
pour attester
ces dieux
manifestés en chair.
La réalité,
c'est que nous avons
à voir
ou nous avons eu
par objectif
de considérer
cette résolution.
Nous voulons
renouveler
notre piété
par la contemplation,
par la déclaration,
par la célébration
du plus grand
de tous les mystères
qui ont été révélés,
les mystères
de la piété.
Et ce que nous devons faire,
c'est d'analyser
chacune de ces facettes
de considérer
pour chacune
de ces facettes
son aspect incontestable
car l'emphase
de l'apôtre Paul ici,
c'est
votre foi
doit être ferme.
Timothée,
malgré les persécutions,
malgré
l'apostasie,
même déjà
dans les jours
de Paul,
de Timothée,
malgré cette impression
que nous avons
que l'Église
était déjà
en train de faillir
être supprimée
comme si elle était
vulnérable
à la persécution
ou dépendante
d'un Timothée
qui était quand même
assez hésitant
dans sa foi.
Voilà pourquoi
Paul écrit ces lettres.
Et Paul est en train
de dire
Timothée,
tant que tu sois
concentré
dans la considération
de ces faits
incontestables,
ta foi
sera inébranlable.
Les mondes
peuvent venir
contre toi
et si tes yeux
sont fixés
sur celui
qui est assis
sur les trônes,
l'Église sera toujours
la majorité,
même étant
la minorité numérique.
et donc
il veut déclarer
comme incontestable
ces faits.
Et il veut aussi
manifester
l'aspect glorieux
de ces faits.
Dieu manifesté
en chair.
Donc pour nous,
afin de raviver
notre piété,
nous devons contempler,
déclarer,
célébrer
les six facettes
qui sont révélées ici
sur la manifestation
des dieux en chair.
Ce qu'on a déjà vu,
on a déjà considéré
quatre et j'espère
qu'on puisse conclure
avec les deux dernières
aujourd'hui.
Donc la première chose,
c'est que pour raviver
notre piété,
nous devons contempler,
déclarer,
célébrer
l'effet incontestable
de la manifestation
des dieux en chair,
c'est lui
qui a été manifesté
en chair.
La vérité,
c'est une personne,
la douzième personne
de la Trinité,
Dieu les fils
qui s'est manifesté
en chair
et cela a été
incontestable.
On a vu
de quelle manière
les pères
ont rendu témoignage
à propos du fils,
les fils ont rendu témoignage
à propos de lui-même
en tant que fils de Dieu
en chair
et donc
c'était une nécessité
même pour notre foi
qu'on ait un médiateur
qui soit véritablement
homme
et véritablement
Dieu.
Pour faire la médiation
entre Dieu et homme,
il faut qu'il soit Dieu
sans être contaminé
par les péchés
dans un corps
véritablement humain
pour pouvoir être
un vrai représentant
de notre race
et pour accomplir
dans sa chair
l'obéissance parfaite
que personne n'arrive
à accomplir
et subir
à la croix
aussi dans sa chair
la punition
qu'on méritait
à propos
de nos péchés.
Nous avions besoin
d'un médiateur parfait
entre Dieu
et les hommes
ce qui les sacrificateurs
de l'Ancien Testament
n'était qu'une ombre
et lui,
il était le vrai.
et donc on a considéré
que cette nécessité
pour notre salut
et rédemption
a été accomplie
car les Christs,
les Fils des Dieux
a été manifesté
en chair.
Pour raviver
notre piété,
nous devons contempler,
déclarer et célébrer aussi
la manière incontestable
dont les Saint-Esprit
a révendiqué
que les Christs
étaient véritablement
les Fils des Dieux
envoyés
pour accomplir
cette rédemption,
son rôle messianique.
Donc les Saint-Esprits,
il était participant
dans la conception
du Christ.
Les Saint-Esprits,
il a manifesté
son onction
comme les vrais Messies
lorsqu'il Christ a été baptisé
et que les Saint-Esprits
descendent comme une colombe.
Mais c'est surtout
en Rome en chapitre 1
qu'il peut dire
qu'il est Saint-Esprit
à révendiquer
ou à déclarer
qu'il était
les vrais Fils des Dieux,
les vrais Messies,
par la résurrection
d'entre les morts.
Donc la résurrection
d'entre les hommes,
c'est la preuve suprême
qu'il ne pouvait pas
être retenu par la mort
car il était
Dieu lui-même.
Et c'est par là
que la Béodique
et le Saint-Esprit
va révendiquer
qu'il est Fils des Dieux,
qu'il est Christ
et qu'il est Fils des Dieux.
Et ça,
c'était incontestable
car les témoignages
publics du Saint-Esprit
à propos
du rôle messianique
ou l'identité messianique
du Fils des Dieux
en Jésus-Christ
était incontestable
pour sa génération,
pour ceux qui sont exposés
à l'enregistrement
des Écritures
et la manière
dont il l'est fait
encore aujourd'hui
à travers l'Église.
Le troisième point pour nous,
c'était de considérer
cette autre expression,
elle a été vue
par les anges.
Donc c'est pour mettre
l'emphase
sur la manière
dont les anges
ont exercé
un rôle
des témoignages
par rapport
à la venue du Christ.
Et là,
c'est intéressant
par rapport
à l'identité divine
du Christ
et son accomplissement
messianique.
Donc ils étaient
présents
à la naissance du Christ
pour les confirmer,
même avant
pour annoncer
la manière
dont les Saint-Esprits
allaient engendrer
les Christs
de la Verge
sans la contamination
de la race humaine.
Mais c'est surtout aussi
la manière
dont les anges
non seulement
ont accompagné
tous les ministères
du Christ,
mais la manière
dont ils ont célébré,
déclaré,
dont ils chantent
cette gloire
de la révélation
du Fils des Dieu,
dont ils sont intéressés
à notre salut
et la manière
dont ils ont rendu
témoignage
du Christ
ressuscité
et les Christs
qui étaient
montés dans la gloire.
Comme on a vu.
Donc l'importance
de la fiabilité
du témoignage
des anges.
Ce qu'on a vu
dimanche dernier,
c'était l'incontestable
proclamation
de l'Évangile.
Et ça,
c'est très intéressant.
Alors ici,
selon
la ferme conviction
de l'Église primitive,
nous sommes devant
une autre facette
qui cherche
à manifester
ou à constater
ou à attester
de manière
incontestable
que les Christs
étaient véritablement
les fils des dieux,
les vrais messies.
Et c'est intéressant.
Car parfois,
on pense qu'il faut
considérer
ces deux facettes
ensemble.
Proclamé au païen
!
devant une preuve
incontestable
que les Christs
étaient les vrais messies
ressuscités
et qu'ils se manifestaient
particulièrement
à travers la prédication
de l'Église
aux païens.
Donc déjà,
la définition biblique
du mystère lui-même
qui concerne l'Évangile,
le plus grand
de tous les mystères.
Comme les plans
et la promesse
des dieux,
c'était
qu'ils les saluent
arrivent à toutes les nations
à travers
les peuples juifs
et comme les développements
de l'histoire d'Israël
pour pouvoir entraîner
toutes les nations
dans les catégories
des exigences
de la sanctification
des dieux
de la manière exacte
par laquelle
les vrais sacrifices
viendraient.
Les temps
que ça a pris
pour développer
ces catégories
au long de l'histoire
ont pu donner
l'impression
aux nations païennes
et à la nation juive
qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'espoir
pour des nations
si païennes
comme la plupart
car même
leurs sociétés
sont devenues
explicitement
plus immorales.
Mais de l'autre côté,
il y a eu aussi
une hypocrisie
énorme
de la part des juifs
qui sont arrivés
à considérer
qu'ils seraient
les seuls
favorisés
par ces saluts
très centrés
sur eux-mêmes
et sont devenus
très accrochés
à la compréhension
tout simplement
externe des lois.
Mais dès le départ,
Dieu avait promis,
il avait annoncé
la bonne nouvelle
à Abraham
que de sa descendance
toutes les nations
seraient justifiées.
Ces mystères
restent occultes
pour la plupart
de l'histoire
mais lorsqu'il est
christian,
il l'accomplit,
il dévoile
cette partie
du mystère
et Paul
lui-même
va avoir
un rôle particulier
pour démontrer
que cela a été
toujours
le plan
de Dieu.
Et le problème,
c'est que
ce qui va
renforcer
l'aspect
incontestable
de la manifestation
du Christ ressuscité
à travers
la proclamation
de l'Église,
c'est le fait
qu'il y a
les apôtres déjà
ce qui devrait être
considéré
comme quelque chose
à contre-coeur,
contre la nature,
contre leur éducation,
leur nationalisme.
Ce sont les juifs
eux-mêmes
qui sont appelés
par Christ d'abord
à proclamer
l'Évangile
aux autres nations.
Ensuite,
et non seulement
le Christ lui-même
donne cet ordre
à l'Église,
mais dans
les mystères du Christ
déjà,
on avait vu
comment il a étendu
cet Évangile
à des membres
d'autres nations.
Et c'est surtout
à partir
de la descente
du Saint-Esprit,
dans les livres
d'actes
et pour la suite
de l'histoire
de l'Église,
où non seulement
les juifs
vont commencer
à prêcher l'Évangile
et proclamer
l'Évangile
aux autres nations,
surprenant
pour les juifs
eux-mêmes,
surprenant aussi
pour les païens,
mystère révélé,
aucune distinction
entre les nations,
finalement,
tous en Christ.
Mais par contre,
il y avait plein
de persécutions
de la part des juifs
qui voulaient au maximum,
comme les judaïsants,
traiter les convertis
païens comme cousins,
mais pas comme frères.
et non seulement
les apôtres
proclament
cet Évangile
aux païens,
mais ils le font
non seulement
contre ce qui devrait
être la nature
ou la culture,
ils le font aussi
contre la persécution.
Ils vont même
donner leur vie
pour proclamer
l'Évangile
et la majorité
des apôtres
sont morts,
martyrisés
dans des nations païennes.
Et donc,
c'est un témoignage
très impactant
que l'apôtre Paul
va expliquer
en 2e Corinthiens 5
comment il est temps
Dieu,
attention,
exhorte à travers nous
et nous vous en souplions,
réconcilier avec Dieu.
Il a mis en nous
la parole
de réconciliation,
c'est-à-dire
jusqu'aujourd'hui,
lorsqu'il est
l'Église
prêche l'Évangile
à toutes les nations,
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui est en train
de se manifester
à travers l'Église.
Et on a mis en face
sur l'importance,
la centralité
de la proclamation,
de la prédication
comme moyen
des manifestations
palpables
des dieux.
Et par là,
l'Église va attester
dans sa génération,
va porter sa contribution
à la manifestation
incontestable
des dieux en chair.
C'est glorieux.
Et nous allons passer
donc aujourd'hui
à la prochaine considération.
Donc,
afin de raviver
notre piété,
nous devons célébrer
et déclarer
avec confiance
l'effet incontestable
que ces Christ
manifestés en chair
a été cru
dans les mondes.
Donc,
c'est très intéressant
de nous rappeler.
Nous sommes devant
un champ
qui est classifié
comme chiasmique,
c'est-à-dire
il y a des croisements
dans la structure
de ces champs
et il y a des mouvements
très intéressants.
Donc,
on va considérer
cette condescendance divine,
les dieux des gloires
qui se manifestent
en chair,
donc une descente.
et on reste dans cette essence
car la manifestation
du Christ
qui s'est vidée
de sa gloire
dans sa chair
a été justifiée
par l'esprit.
Et là,
on monte à nouveau.
La chair et l'esprit.
Ensuite,
cet esprit
qui a révendiqué
les Christ
comme fils des dieux
en chair,
il a été davantage
corroboré comme tel
car les anges
l'ont vu.
Et donc,
il y a
de la chair
montant à l'esprit.
L'esprit,
on reste en haut
avec cette représentation
de la patrie céleste
qui sait
les témoignages
des anges
qui sera contrasté
donc
par
celui qui a été
proclamé
à toutes les nations,
aux païens.
Et là,
on revient sur terre.
Et celui
qui a été révélé,
qui a été proclamé
à tous les païens
a été cru dans les mondes.
Donc,
on reste en bas.
Et on conclut
les cycles
avec cette manifestation
du Christ en chair
qui est élevé
dans la gloire.
Et donc,
c'est très beau
de considérer ces choses
et voilà pourquoi
c'est important
d'être sûr
que pour plus
que proclamé
dans les mondes,
pardon,
proclamé aux païens
et cru dans les mondes
soit
quelque part connecté,
c'est important
de considérer
chaque portion
des contributions.
Et donc,
c'est ce que l'apôtre Paul
est en train de confirmer ici
par la citation
de cette confession
de ces chants,
c'est qu'il est fait
incontestable
que ces Christ
manifestés en chair
ressuscité
a été cru
dans les mondes
est une preuve
incontestable
de la réalité
des dieux fils
manifestés en chair.
Et donc,
ça c'est très important
pour nous de considérer.
Et la première question
qu'on se pose,
c'est pourquoi
pouvons-nous affirmer
que c'est une vérité
incontestable.
Donc là,
nous voyons,
déjà,
il a été proclamé
aux païens
et par là,
on voit quelque part
les échos
de cette grande commission
qui Christ a donnée
après sa résurrection
aux disciples.
Aller proclamer
l'évangile
à toutes les nations.
Donc,
l'emphase
mise
sur ces points,
c'est
« J'essaierai avec vous ».
Dans un certain sens,
ne pensez pas
trop au résultat.
Quelle motivation
auraient les disciples
avant la Pentecôte
d'y aller ?
La promesse,
les Christ,
ils donnent.
Toute autorité
m'a été donnée
sur les sels
et sur la terre.
Donc,
je vais
occuper
ma position,
mon siège
suprême
de l'histoire.
Et la réalité,
c'est que
lorsque les disciples
sont dans l'attente
d'accomplir
cette mission,
les Christ lui-même,
avant de partir
à la gloire,
va dire
« Attendez
jusqu'à ce que
les Saintes Esprits
viennent sous vous
et vous allez être
mes témoins
pour accomplir
dans toutes les nations. »
C'est la plus grande
bénédiction.
Et non seulement
ils partent
avec cette puissance
pour attester
que Dieu,
les fils,
est vivant
à travers leur vie,
car ils sont
boostés
par cette vie
qui les amène
à prêcher
même devant
la persécution,
mais ils sont
quand même
commissionnés
à proclamer
l'évangile
aux mêmes
multitudes
qui ont
crucifié
les Christ.
Ces Christ
qui avaient
été justifiés
par l'Esprit,
qui avaient opéré
des miracles,
enseigné la vérité
avec autorité,
avec puissance,
et la multitude
avaient
rejeté
les Christ.
Qu'est-ce
qui prouve
davantage
que son œuvre
était accomplie
et qu'à partir
du moment
où on voit
la foi
répandue
dans les mondes,
y compris
par ceux
qui avaient
rejeté
les Christ,
c'est une preuve
incontestable
qu'à partir
du moment
où les mondes
progressent
dans la croyance,
dans la ferme conviction
dans l'évangile,
nous sommes devant
une preuve
incontestable
du fait
que Dieu
est véritablement
manifesté en chair
et qu'il continue
de se manifester
à travers
la croissance
de la foi
de l'Église.
C'est très important,
cru dans les mondes.
Donc la première chose
qu'on doit définir ici,
c'est la foi.
Il a été cru
dans les mondes
et croire
selon la conception
biblique
et la description
biblique,
à nouveau,
n'est pas
la crédulité
aveugle.
Nous sommes
devant les faits
incontestables.
Nous sommes en train
de parler
des faits historiques
sur lesquels
s'ébase
notre foi.
Et croire,
c'est d'avoir
une ferme conviction.
Si Timothée
dans ses jours
est devant
l'enconstance
de la foi
de certains
et l'apostasie
d'autres,
la perte
de la persécution
qui mène
certains chrétiens
à osciller
dans leur foi.
Si certains
ont de la honte
envers l'évangile
et qui n'arrivent pas
à proclamer la vérité
de manière publique,
si c'est le cas
pour nous,
si c'était le cas
pour nous
jusqu'à 2024.
Paul est en train
de nous rappeler
que nous avons
des bases
suffisantes,
des enregistrements
historiques
qui nous montrent
que Dieu manifestait
un chair
a été cru
dans les mondes.
Lorsque nous avons
l'oscillation
de notre foi,
la honte
de proclamer
la vérité,
on devrait
mettre en question
déjà
la qualité
de notre connaissance
biblique,
la qualité
de notre piété,
peut-être
l'authenticité
même de notre foi.
Car nous n'avons pas
qu'est-ce que
cette génération
très affaiblie
à plusieurs égards
en termes
de professer
avec conviction
sa foi publiquement,
se faire taire
jusqu'à
Rwana,
menacé
par des pressions
sociales
lorsque la Constitution
nous permet encore
de partager
la foi publiquement,
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait
faire ?
Révenir
sur les enregistrements
historiques,
bibliques
et l'histoire
de l'Église
et voir
de quelles races
sont faites
les vrais chrétiens.
Et là,
je dis race
en termes spirituels.
Et ce qu'on va retrouver,
c'est une Église
dans une première génération
sous persécution
qui proclame
la vérité
et qui est emprisonnée.
Les anges
les relâchent,
ils prêchent à nouveau,
ils sont frappés
par des coups
de verge.
Ils continuent
de prêcher,
ils sont morts
en prêchant.
Et ça,
ce n'est pas
qu'un épisode
qu'on va retrouver,
en acte.
Ça,
c'est manifesté
au long
de l'histoire
de l'Église.
Non seulement
la proclamation
qui est une expression
des fermes convictions,
mais une efficacité
qui sera
quelque part
proportionnelle
à la ferme conviction
qu'on proclame.
Si nous voulons voir
ou avoir la joie
et la motivation
et l'assurance
pour voir les fruits
et les résultats,
il faut d'abord
s'aimer.
Comment vont-ils croire
si personne n'est prêche ?
Si vous voulez voir
que les personnes croient,
proclamez.
La promesse du Christ,
c'est
ouvrez bien
votre bouche
et je mettrai
les paroles
dans vos bouches,
le Saint-Esprit.
Si on n'ouvre pas
la bouche,
si on n'est pas
résolu à participer,
comment nous serons
motivés
par la conversion
de ceux
qui passent à croire ?
Ce n'est pas
susceptible
au temps
aux époques.
C'est susceptible
à la stirpe,
à la nature,
à la force
spirituelle
d'une église,
à la ferme conviction.
Les crises
ressuscitées
ont été crus
dans les mondes
malgré
la difficulté
de croire.
Par exemple,
depuis la naissance
de Jésus-Christ,
il a été
cru dans les mondes.
Parmi
une génération
qui doutait
que les Messies
auraient pu naître
de cette manière
si simple,
on a vu
Homme
dans les temples,
on a vu
non seulement
d'entre les Juifs
ceux qui ont cru
à l'annonce
de la naissance
du Christ,
mais on a vu
même les sages
de l'Orient,
les païens,
qui sont venus
pour manifester
leur foi
en Christ.
avec une telle
fermeté
que même
devant l'autorité,
ils ont
proclamé
la vérité.
Avec une telle
fermeté
que malgré
l'ordre
de revenir
à lui
après avoir
rencontré
le Christ,
ils vont
s'échapper
pour obéir
plutôt à Dieu
que les hommes.
depuis la naissance
du Christ,
même ses
oppositeurs,
cette autorité,
a cru quand même
qu'il était
les Messies,
car il a voulu
les supprimer,
les persécuter.
Pendant son ministère,
on voit la conversion
des Juifs,
des païens,
on voit
de manière
très claire
comment
Zaki et
les Juifs
vont se convertir,
comment la femme
samaritaine
qui était un hybride
presque païen,
comment on voit
la guérison
de la femme
canadienne
qui est aussi
païenne,
la guérison
de l'aveugle
né
juif,
les voleurs
répentirent la croix
qui a participé
à sa crucifixion
et qui est le premier
à faire la déclaration
de foi
qu'il a faite.
Véritablement,
cet homme était
fils de Dieu.
Mais c'est surtout
après sa résurrection
que la chose
devient plus liée
à l'objectif
de ces passages,
car ces passages
ont pour but
manifesté
de manière très claire
que la résurrection
ou l'œuvre complète
du Christ
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
élevé la gloire
soit attesté,
qu'il y ait
d'assurance
par rapport à ça.
Et quand on voit,
par exemple,
la manière
dont les apôtres
ont cru
à la résurrection
du Christ,
les femmes,
c'est très intéressant
de les remarquer
par plusieurs passages
que même
ils hésitaient
à croire
à la résurrection.
Luc 24,
36 et 37,
tandis qu'il parlait
de ces choses,
Jésus lui-même
s'est présenté
en milieu d'eux,
donc les schéments
des Maïs,
les disciples,
et leur dit,
la paix soit avec vous,
dans la frayeur
et la surprise,
ils crurent voir
un esprit d'abord.
Ensuite,
verset 41,
comme ils ne croyaient
pas encore
et qu'ils étaient
dans la joie
et dans l'étonnement,
il leur dit,
avez-vous ici
quelque chose
à manger ?
Et ils lui donnèrent
en morceaux
des poissons grillés
qu'ils prient
et mangent à des vends.
Ce que Christ
s'intendait faire,
c'est avec son corps
ressuscité,
qui reste quand même
encore humant,
il est en train
de prouver
par le fait
qu'il est en train
de manger
qu'il était
véritablement
ressuscité.
En Marc 16,
la fin de l'évangile
de Marc,
nous voyons aussi
la manière
dont les femmes
hésitent à croire
dans la résurrection.
Après que Jésus
fut ressuscité
les matins,
les premiers jours
de la semaine,
il apparut d'abord
à Marie,
Madeleine,
de laquelle
il avait chassé
cette démon.
elle alla annoncer
à ceux
qui avaient été
avec lui
et qui étaient
dans les deuils
et en pleurs.
Lorsqu'ils
entaient à dire
qu'ils vivaient
et qu'elle
l'avait vu,
ils n'y crurent pas.
Après cela,
il se manifesta
sous une autre forme
à deux d'entre eux
qui étaient en chemin,
s'y rendant
à la campagne.
Ils allaient annoncer
aux autres
qu'ils ne les crurent
pas non plus.
enfants,
ils se montra
aux onze eux-mêmes
pendant qu'ils étaient
à table
et il leur réprochait
de leur incrédulité
et de la dureté
de leur cœur
parce qu'ils n'avaient
pas cru
ceux qui l'avaient
vu ressusciter.
On a d'autres passages
qui vont dire
la même chose.
Je crois que c'est
qu'on arrive à Thomas
qui avait raté
cette réunion
de l'Église.
D'ailleurs,
l'Ordal
utilise cet exemple
pour quoi,
ou quelle serait
la plus importante
des raisons,
ou l'une
des plus importantes,
qu'on ne devrait pas
rater les réunions
de prière
ou les cultes
des dimanches.
Et ils disent
c'est car on ne sait
jamais lorsque Dieu
va opérer
de manière
glorieuse,
surnaturelle,
de manière
puissante
entre nous.
Imaginez
Christ qui avait
apparu
aux disciples
et Thomas
qui avait raté
cette réunion
qui aurait pu
ne pas avoir
contemplé les Christ
ressuscité.
Et là,
les Christ
dans sa condescendance
va apparaître
à nouveau
pour confirmer
et montrer
les marques
de son sacrifice
pour que Thomas
soit sûr
que c'était
les Christ
lui-même.
Mais dans
ces mêmes passages,
les Christ
va dire
heureux ceux
qui n'ont pas
vu
et qui ont
cru.
Et qui ont
cru
fermément.
C'est pour ça
que c'est très
intéressant de remarquer
que ça fait partie
du mystère
dévoilé,
la participation
du Saint-Esprit
vis-à-vis
de notre foi.
Car ces mêmes
disciples qui étaient
hésitants,
même devant
les Christ
ressuscités
lui-même,
sont les mêmes
qui vont partir
pour proclamer
et mourir
martyrisés
en proclamant,
en ayant au centre
de leur message
les Christ
ressuscités.
Et à partir
du moment
où ils mouraient
proclamant
l'Évangile,
ils passaient
à la gloire
directement
pour contempler
la réalité
qu'ils proclamaient.
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que eux,
ils ont passé
à croire
fermement
que Paul,
par exemple,
en première
correntienne,
va démontrer
la première partie
du chapitre 15,
une citation
d'une déclaration
des fois
vis-à-vis
aux preuves
évidentes
et incontestables
de la résurrection
du Christ.
à qui l'Écrit
s'est montré
d'abord,
à qui il s'est montré
après,
les 500 personnes
qui ont été témoignages,
qui l'ont vu,
combien de jours
Christ a passé
ressuscité
avec les disciples
pour qu'on ait
aucun doute.
Ces apôtres
qui n'avaient
aucun intérêt
personnel,
ces apôtres
qui,
quand ils sont
analysés
chacun
par sa partie
ou sa contribution
ou ses écrits,
sont vus
évidemment
comme des personnes
intelligentes
qui ne peuvent pas
être diagnostiquées
par la clarté
de leur raisonnement
comme étant fous,
qui ont
la même difficulté
de croire
à la résurrection
que nous
pourrions avoir.
Et donc,
c'est impossible
de chercher
à définir
la croyance
ou la foi
affermie
dans un Christ
ressuscité
et de l'écréditer
à une folie
collective.
Mais là,
1 Corinthiens 15,
elle nous donne
plein d'épreuves.
Et les preuves
ne sont pas
si tant
établies
tout simplement
sur les témoignages
oculaires
comme dit
l'apôtre Pierre,
mais c'est surtout
la ferme conviction
de celui
qui vient
à croire
par le Saint-Esprit.
Car bien heureux
ceux qui n'ont pas vu
et qui ont cru.
Et comme je vous ai dit,
les résultats
de leur prédication
étaient la croissance
de l'Église.
Tous les mondes anciens,
par tous les mondes anciens,
la foi,
malgré la persécution,
à point qui est
Tertullien,
on va dire
les saints des martyrs
et la sémence
de l'Église.
C'est une preuve
incontestable
que celui
qui est monté
au trône
est en train
de faire avancer
son Église
car des personnes
de toutes les nations
sont en train
de croire fermement.
Donc non seulement
les apôtres ont cru,
les disciples,
on arrive à Paul
qui était
en pleine persécution
d'Église
et une intervention
extraordinaire
a lieu.
Les crises
qui avaient déjà été
élevées dans la gloire
vont se manifester
à lui
personnellement,
ressuscités.
et Paul
qui tombe par terre
et qui croit
et qui devient
l'un des plus
importants prédicateurs
de la résurrection.
On voit comment
de manière
extraordinaire
les mondes anciens
ont vu
la croissance
et l'Église
et comment
les Juifs
et les païens
ont cru
avec l'Évangile
bien sûr
majoritairement
étant à partir
de là
répandu
entre les païens
et des livres
d'actes
nous montrent ça.
L'Église passe
les 150 personnes
par la première
prédication des pierres
à 3000.
Ensuite,
chapitres 4 et 5,
on va s'approcher
des 5000
et ensuite
on perd les comptes.
Tellement nombreuses
étaient la croyance
des personnes
qui ont cru
malgré la persécution,
ont cru
dans les crises
ressuscités
et que même
les oppositeurs
de l'Église
essayaient
d'emprisonner
les prédicateurs
de l'Évangile
en démontrant
par là aussi
comme Gamaliel
lui-même
a attesté
la possibilité
qu'ils étaient
en train
de lutter
contre Dieu.
Tellement puissant
est le témoignage
d'une Église
lorsqu'elle est
ensemble
en train
de chanter
sa foi,
en train
de croire
fermement,
en train
d'approfondir
leurs convictions,
d'expérimenter
la manifestation
des dieux
entre nous.
Acte 2,
l'Église
est là
en train
de participer
aux fondements,
persévérer
dans les fondements
des apôtres,
étudier la parole
des dieux
constamment,
les partages
du pain,
la sainte scène,
etc.
Elle est en train
d'approfondir
de manière
intellectuelle
et expérimentale
sa foi,
ses convictions
et le Seigneur
ajouta
à chaque jour
ce qui était sauvé.
Donc là,
il y a un lien
entre la proclamation
et la conversion.
Il y a aussi
un lien
entre la fermeté
de notre croyance,
de notre profession
publique des fois,
être Église,
persévérer
ici tous les dimanches,
et devenir
une manifestation
de la réalité
de l'Évangile.
On pense
que l'Évangile
va avancer
par nos stratégies.
On pense
que c'est par
l'adaptation
à la culture
actuelle.
On pense
qu'on doit réduire
les temps
de prédication,
de rendre
les choses
plus didactiques,
éviter de toucher
aux points
de confrontation
sauf que
l'Église
nous montre,
la Bible nous montre
de manière très claire
un rapport
entre
une ferme conviction
!
et la croissance
de l'Église.
Si nous voulons
déclarer
avec plus de conviction,
il faut qu'on
s'approfondisse
plus dans la Bible.
si on veut
adorer
avec plus
d'affection,
il faut
qu'on contemple
de manière
plus biblique
la gloire
de notre Dieu.
Si on n'est pas
en train
d'être diligent
dans la contemplation
de ces vérités,
d'approfondir
notre manière
d'attester,
de confirmer
comment pouvons-nous
déclarer
avec la même force?
En neutre,
on aura,
on va communiquer
plus tôt
si une Église
n'est pas,
c'est important,
même lorsqu'une Église
est en train
d'implanter
de faire un travail
dans un lieu
où les personnes
n'ont pas été
privilégiées
en termes d'éducation,
l'Église ne doit
jamais mépriser
la capacité
et l'intention
de Dieu
d'élever
les niveaux
de connaissance
de ces personnes
car la sagesse
selon Dieu
vient de la connaissance
biblique
et ces choses
ont été révélées
pour les peuples
de Dieu.
Elle peut
n'y pas avoir
une articulation
ou un vocabulaire
qui puisse sonner
académique
dans la société
mais elle aura
une connaissance
qu'elle ait traité
par les Christ
lui-même
comme lumière
du monde.
Et l'Église
n'a jamais été
appelée
pour rendre
les personnes
enfantiles.
Lorsque les personnes
en dehors
nous voient
et nous voient
assembler
et analysent
notre culte
et qu'elles ont
l'impression
qu'elles nous sont
traités
comme des bêtes
qui n'ont
qu'à la capacité
de se divertir
des joueurs
des chants
rock'n'roll
ça donne l'impression
d'une foi
qui n'a pas
des bases fermes
ça donne l'impression
des fanatismes
ça donne l'idée
d'être
très superstitieux
si ce que nous
pratiquons
au sein de l'Église
n'est pas fondé
sur ces mystères
qui ont été
révélés
ça semble
au gnosticisme
si on est plus
concentré
sur ce qui est
encore caché
superstitieux
ce n'est pas
une foi
tout simplement
attirante
et la réalité
c'est que
lorsqu'une Église
est bien instruite
par la parole
des dieux
ces affections
vont inévitablement
s'approfondir
et s'élargir
car elles sont
ancrées
dans des vérités
glorieuses
et bibliques
discernables
voilà pourquoi
entre autres
pour faire les liens
avec les mondes
offrandes
les églises
ont besoin
des hommes
des dieux
de la parole
à temps plein
consacré
afin
d'instruire
d'éduquer
de servir
des modèles
et le fait
que toutes les nations
croient
ça c'est aussi un point
important dans la génération
car même
si au long de l'histoire
certaines nations
ont réagité
ou refusé
l'évangile
l'Église
a quand même
grandi
dans ces mêmes nations
sous la pression
et si la persécution
s'est intensifiée
ils sont partis
en s'enfuyant
c'est les cas
comme résultat
de la persécution
à Jérusalem
où les chrétiens
laïcs
ce sont eux
qui sont allés
répandre la foi
et c'est les cas
aussi en France
donc les juguino
sont partis
envers plusieurs nations
et ont contribué
énormément
à la croissance
de la foi
partout dans le monde
la croissance
est inévitable
et une preuve
incontestable
de Dieu
manifester en Chéa
et dès le départ
l'Église
c'est naturel
dans les passés
dans les villes
où il n'y avait pas
beaucoup d'étrangers
que l'Église
soit caractérisée
par la nation
qui était
par contre
dans toutes ces villes
qui étaient un peu
des capitales mondiales
on voit combien
hybrides
étaient les églises
en termes ethniques
ou culturels
et ça peut nous fatiguer
parfois
de considérer
que Dieu aurait pu
avoir un public cible
pour une telle église
ou pour une autre église
alors là
c'est une église
pour les jeunes
c'est pour ça
qu'elle est comme ça
ou faire
des églises
ethniques
qui est parfois
peut-être
exceptionnel
mais l'une des richesses
et des preuves
incontestables
de Dieu
manifester en Chéa
en Jésus-Christ
c'est surtout
la capacité
que cette foi
intelligente
basée sur des faits
historiques
et la réalité
spirituelle
du Saint-Esprit
elle a une capacité
surnaturelle
de nous faire
surmonter
nos différences
les plus hétérogènes
les plus internationales
est une église
les plus proches
de la vision céleste
de la vraie église
perpétuelle
de la gloire
et donc il faut
qu'on fasse attention
de quelle manière
une église
très accrochée
à ses propres
ethnies
ou cultures
ne peut devenir
un indice
plutôt
d'un nationalisme
ou un ethnocentrisme
qu'une évidence
est la preuve
Dieu
s'est manifesté
en Chéa
de manière incontestable
car moi
je peux
entretenir
de la
de la conversation
plaisante
avec
quelqu'un
qui n'a rien
à voir avec moi
à part Christ
à part notre foi
qui est en commun
et cette foi
qui est la seule chose
qui nous avons en commun
concerne
ce qui est
des plus importants
par rapport
à moi
et à lui
voilà pourquoi
Lloyd-Jones
malgré toutes les opportunités
qu'il avait
en ayant
travaillé
comme médecin
même
assistant
de la reine
d'Angleterre
avec tout son
succès professionnel
convié au cercle
le plus élevé
de la société
de Londres
il disait
j'ai plus
de plaisir
avec les membres
les plus simples
de mon église
qui est d'être
dans ces maisons
avec les non-croyants
ça c'est une preuve
incontestable
de la réalité
de Christ
entre nous
combien hétérogène
est une église
combien nous
individuellement
nous faisons des efforts
au lieu de rester
dans notre zone
de confort
comme certaines églises
se situent avec
les groupes
d'affinités
on n'a pas besoin
des groupes
d'affinités
pour qu'on ait
cette tendance
naturelle
à aller chercher
ceux qui sont
les plus similaires
à nous
c'est dont on a besoin
c'est d'insister
à varier
le plus
qui est possible
nos relations
au sein d'une église
et d'approfondir
le plus
qui est possible
nos relations
avec elle
ça c'est une preuve
incontestable
non seulement
il a été cru
dans les mondes
partout
et lorsqu'on peut
faire un voyage
et visiter des églises
dans l'autre extrême
de la planète
nous allons trouver
qu'on a plus en commun
avec elle
que notre collègue
de travail
c'est important aussi
de remarquer ici
les liens
donc bien sûr
qu'on va devoir attendre
pour conclure cette série
les dimanches prochains
je suis désolé
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
l'emphase
mise
dans ces passages
à propos
de la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
quel est le lien
entre
Dieu était
incontestablement
manifesté
en chair
car il était cru
dans les mondes
c'est car c'est lui
qui a été élevé
dans la gloire
attention
même si c'était
celui
qui avait été
crucifié
malgré
la manifestation
publique
des miracles
qu'il a opéré
des enseignements
les plus élevés
qu'on puisse imaginer
on ne peut pas
imaginer
qu'un évangéliste
même Billy Grant
si vous voulez
soit plus capable
d'évangéliser
que les Christs
et la réalité
c'est que la réussite
la réponse
à cet évangile
ne dépend pas
de nos stratégies
de nos capacités
et donc c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
c'est que
c'est que Jésus
est en train de faire
c'était d'accomplir
son œuvre
qui ne s'arrête pas
dans la mort
ni dans la résurrection
du Christ
pendant qu'il était
sur terre
donc nous pouvons
être sûrs
que l'Église
va avancer
car comme Daniel
avait prophétisé
toutes les nations
tous les empires
pour plus développer
qu'ils soient
et pour plus
qu'ils semblent avoir
de la force
de longue durée
ils auront
une date
d'expiration
et il y aura
cette pierre
d'achoppement
qui aura la capacité
de pulvériser
toutes les nations
et c'est le seul royaume
qui traversera
toutes les nations
avec réussite
nous pouvons
ne pas être
la majorité
dans toutes les générations
ceux qui croient
et particulièrement
fermement
mais
pendant toute l'histoire
de l'humanité
l'Église
aura
ses fermes
représentants
et les progrès
de l'Évangile
aura lieu
c'est
évidemment
d'être devant
la liaison
entre la souveraineté
des dieux
manifestés en chair
et l'évangélisation
que nous sommes
même Billy Grant
son petit-fils
son petit-enfant
a dit un jour
que les livres
qui étaient les plus
utilisés
c'était
la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
de Diéry Packer
pourquoi
nous pouvons sortir
pour proclamer
la vérité
c'est la réponse
que Spurgeon a donnée
dans une des générations
les plus sceptiques
pendant que
toutes les églises
sont fragilisées
proclament
l'Évangile
chaque fois
avec moins
de convictions
moins de voix
héraldiques
pourquoi
ou comment
tu expliquerais
que ton église
croisse
et comment
peux-tu expliquer
cette motivation
pour prêcher
réponse
de Spurgeon
je prêche
avec la certitude
que Dieu
appellera
les siens
car si
je dépends
de ma stratégie
ou de leur
prédisposition
à croire
on est complètement
perdu
tous sont privés
de la gloire
de Dieu
par nature
ennemis
de Dieu
et ici
nous sommes devant
le fait
que
la progression
de la foi
partout dans le monde
est une évidence
que Dieu
est au travail
et cela ne peut pas
nous amener
à négliger
le fait
que Dieu
a décidé
de sauver
les perdus
à travers
la proclamation
de l'Église
je dois
exercer
mon rôle
avec responsabilité
m'engager
avec la ferme
certitude
que le plus
je l'ai fait
le plus
Dieu aura
le plaisir
d'accomplir
son œuvre
à travers
ma vie
et donc
cette preuve
incontestable
du fait
qu'il est Christ
était Dieu
manifesté
en chair
elle s'affiche
par l'effet
qu'il y a
six sous-centre
de gloire
il a présenté
son sacrifice
il est en train
de présenter
son sacrifice
à Dieu
et
appeler
ou appliquer
par son intercession
son œuvre
parfaite
et complète
envers
chacun
de son peuple
élu
qui va
être sauvé
et se convertir
au moment donné
dans leur histoire
nous devons joindre
cette prière
cette proclamation
et ces vérités
glorieuses
qui nous concernent
il n'y a
aucune
à nouveau
signification
plus importante
pour nos vies
aucune
identité
ou fonction
plus élevée
aucune
réalisation
qu'on puisse faire
qui soit
plus importante
qu'il est
privilège
d'être
des outils
pour que Dieu
annonce
l'évangile
à travers nous
et que Dieu
opère sa puissance
pour conduire
à la foi
ceux qui seront
convertis
à travers
notre
participation
considérez bien
une église
qui proclame
est une église
qui accomplit
les moyens nécessaires
pour que
les mondes
croient
mais une église
attention
qui confesse
avec fermeté
qui déclare
ses vérités
qui vient
et se rassemble
pour adorer
pour étudier
pour s'approfondir
est aussi
rien que par la manière
dont on croit
et dont on professe
publiquement
notre foi
nous sommes
une preuve
vivante
et vivifiante
qu'est Dieu
entre nous
même
nos rassemblements
les ordonnances
les baptêmes
et la sainte scène
c'est une manière
d'afficher
publiquement
notre foi
et Dieu
se manifeste
par là
Amen
et
on